today i'm going to be speaking with
jonathan berman who's a professor
national co-chair of the 2017 march for
science and also author of anti-vaxxers
how to challenge a misinformed movement
uh jonathan so great to have you on
today
thank you thank you for having me here
so let's see to start with my conception
of the anti-vaccine movement which which
i've studied over time is that
you have um
right and left wing so-called
anti-vaccine folks often motivated in
different ways i tend to see
the the right-wing anti-vaccine is more
based in skepticism of government
whereas the left-wing anti-vaccine is
more skepticism of big pharma so first
question am i right that this sometimes
crosses political lines is it along the
lines i i laid out
yeah for the most part uh so
up until very recently there wasn't a
big difference between left and right as
far as
vaccine skepticism over the last few
years there's been a pretty big right
word shift
i just was reading a paper
indicating that there's a strong
um the second strongest predictor of
anti-vaccine sentiment right now is
christian nationalism
so there there have been some some
change changes in the demographic makeup
of the anti-vaccine movement like you
would expect with a big event like the
pandemic
going on
what would you say so currently maybe
we'll start now and maybe work backwards
if it makes sense
we've seen
vaccine skepticism over the coronavirus
vaccine decline overall over the last
year i think there was a point last year
where something like 60 of americans
said they weren't interested and that
dropped to 50 and the latest numbers i
saw about 28 28 or 30 percent
is the is the current situation
unique historically or is it typical
that when there is the the surges of a
new communicable disease that there is
more hesitancy that declines
you know i was initially skeptical of
those those survey numbers for the
reason that
for diseases like measles
we
we've seen
you know high degrees of skepticism on
surveys
but then when it comes when the when the
rubber hits the road when it's time to
actually get vaccinated we see very high
numbers of
vaccination high compliance
so there's there's something about the
way those surveys tend to be written
or or something about
the way that
uh that that people respond to them
that
that makes people a little bit
uh
hesitant to say they're going to get it
but then get it
so when it was saying 40 30
i think it's going to be higher than
that
so it's not surprising that as people
get vaccinated people are
are relaxing a little bit about their
skepticism
one of the things i would imagine will
will move some people who might
genuinely be on the skeptical side to
the i want the vaccine side would be if
airlines for example say after a certain
date you'll need to be vaccinated to fly
with us or you can avoid a quarantine if
you're vaccinated or if you want to come
to an event where tickets are sold by
ticketmaster or live nation you'll need
to be vaccinated i think that that that
will certainly be a factor
um but beyond those sort of i want to be
able to do x type of things
what tends to bring people out of
vaccine skepticism
right so as far as what governments can
do
like you said you have these
non-coercive
measures um and ideally we don't want to
be coercing people
um because that's when people become
most resistant
is when they feel like they're being
coerced so
what what seems to help is seeing people
who
belong to the same groups as them
getting vaccinated people who
have
similar backgrounds similar
socioeconomic status
similar race and religion
um
getting vaccinated and the united states
um
so for example there is strong
vaccine hesitancy in the black community
right um but that's partially predicated
on a history of of medical racism
um and addressing that is going to be an
important part of persuading people in
that community may be less important for
persuading
um
orthodox jews or
or white evangelicals
so
i think the most important thing we can
do is to sort of target our messaging
to the groups we're speaking to um
that's interesting yeah the three
currently most vaccine hesitant groups
that i've looked at and again this is as
you mentioned if we can if we can trust
the data
it's black americans
um republicans and those without college
degrees
what would it be that would be more
likely to be um convincing to for
example just republicans
right so
there's this moral foundations theory um
in in psychology that says that
uh people who tend to be more
conservative respond
more to certain
moral foundations that people tend to be
more respond to other moral foundations
right so
the ones that conservatives um
i think respond more to are
sort of disgust
loyalty um and so
we want to frame messaging around those
moral foundations in my opinion so we
would want to
[Music]
you know talk about when people say
these are chemicals these are outside
substances you're putting in your body
what's really in there what does it mean
what's it there for um
and then um
have the discussion with them about
bodily autonomy control over
what medical treatments are being
performed on them and and make sure it's
clear that this is not a case of
government overreach
and that public health measures are an
important
part of the functions of of government
that
um they should hopefully accept yeah
jonathan jonathan height has written a
lot about what you know the the as you
point out the values that
um are more relevant and motivational to
different different groups of people
when it comes to vaccine skepticism
are there examples from history where it
was justified to be skeptical of a
vaccine
um so there have been instances in
history where things have gone wrong
and there were
mistakes made in manufacturing of a
vaccine
or
we're welcoming we're welcoming your dog
to the interview now which is fine the
audience loves dogs
um sadie sees uh
he sees someone outside delivering a
package and she's very angry
say hi to sadie there she is um so yeah
there have been instances in the past
where
mistakes have been made or in
manufacturing or
where
in the 70s there was a
flu pandemic that was predicted that
never came about and there was a vaccine
that very slightly increased the risk of
guillain-barre syndrome right
so
those things have happened in the past
um and that's why it's not unreasonable
to be cautious
right so
that's why we hit we test vaccines with
thousands and thousands of people before
they come to market and that's why
these things are reviewed by government
panels and these are
you know the saying is regulations are
written in blood
um
a lot of these regulations have come
about because of those mistakes
a really big important one
was uh the qatar and wyeth labs incident
in the 1950s
there was about 200 000 doses of polio
vaccine right um
and
the that vaccine design involved live
poliovirus that was inactivated it was
it wasn't killed because viruses aren't
alive but it was made unable to infect
people
with
i believe it was formaldehyde
and it was improperly done
so
this
uh this vaccine that was sent out was
able to infect people
and so about 200 people had a paralyzed
limb where they were injected
or with with that vaccine
um and so that led to the creation of
some of these government agencies that
are responsible for
that regulation
you know one that i've been getting
maybe you know 10 or 12 emails about
over the last few weeks as we've talked
about vaccines is folks who write to me
and say you know david
clearly vaccines can do harm because
there is this vaccine injury
compensation apparatus that the
government uh has has created and that
that wouldn't be there if this wasn't a
thing so therefore
therefore what i guess is the question
right so the
the national vaccine injury compensation
program came about in the 1980s
and there had been a paper in 1974
that alleged
or seemed that seemed to show that there
was
from the tdap vaccine
an increased risk of
neurological problems
and so
that led to people saying oh is that
true and a bunch of studies eventually
we figured out no it's not true
but the consequences of that were a wave
of countries
deciding
that
they would no longer
no longer vaccinate for
i'm sorry dpt vaccine
theriotropism yeah
they would no longer vaccinate for
pertussis
and there was a wave of outbreaks that
followed in those countries where
pertussis came back whooping cough
a lot of sick kids and in the u.s
there were only a handful of companies
that manufactured pertussis vaccine
so lawyers saw this and they decided
okay we're going to start suing these
companies manufacturing dpt and we'll
use this paper as evidence
and so there were there were at least
one i believe possibly two companies
that went out that said we're not going
to make it anymore it's too big a
liability we'll be sued out of existence
and congress saw this and they realized
that
if we continue allowing people to sue
based on flimsy evidence
[Music]
these vaccine manufacturers we won't
have a vaccine
supply so
they kind of came up with this idea
that's not perfect
and which is uh the the national vaccine
injury compensation program
so
excuse me if you are
vaccinated then in the next few days you
develop certain symptoms
you are certain that they have defined
as possible
vaccine injury
they will compensate you
um and you can go to the vaccine court
and the government will compensate you
instead of suing the
vaccine manufacturer out of existence
um and that's not perfect because that
takes away some of the liability if they
actually do do something wrong right
and how common are the claims
um
i don't have the number off the top of
my head it's fairly common for people to
file claims
um they have paid out a lot over time
the trouble is that
the standard of evidence required by the
vaccine court is very different from the
scientific standard of evidence that
um i or other scientists would require
to to say this is this is demonstrated
to my satisfaction as provisionally true
in the lab
right
so it's a standard that that allows
maybe for more successful filings than a
a
a more rigorous method would
yeah um
so legal proceedings don't always track
with scientific methods right
yeah
um listen last thing i wanted to touch
on when it comes to the rollout of the
coronavirus vaccine we now have the
pfizer and moderna vaccines um approved
and they've been out through emergency
use they've been out for a bit i've
received both doses of the moderna we
now have the approved via eua johnson
and johnson we may have a fourth vaccine
on the way i'm reassured right now by
two things one
we have gone from 890 000 vaccinations a
day to 2.1 million that number seems to
continue to climb number two
the latest study i saw in the new
england journal of medicine on uh
effectiveness against the three primary
variants uk brazil and south africa uh
is remains quite good so in total is it
logical to be pretty optimistic right
now about the next four to six months
i am both optimistic and worried
i'm optimistic because
uh for the reasons you state we've done
a we've started to do a good job of
ramping up the rate of vaccination
and the vaccines are pretty good for
those variants
however here's why i'm i'm worried
there are the brazilian and the new york
city variants
um the
brazilian variant seems to escape
immunity from people who've already been
infected with
uh with coronavirus so in other words
vaccines aside vaccines aside if you got
the virus a year ago and then you get
the brazilian variant today you you are
not immune from the old infection you
you may not you may not be okay
um
so that's something to watch and and be
concerned about we don't know yet
that
vaccines don't provide better protection
right um but it's something to be
concerned about and the new york city
variant
um
is still a question mark
it that seems to be infecting people
faster than you would expect given the
number of cases new york city has
already had in other words still not
based on vaccination but based on new
york city having a lot of
early infections
and yet they're having a lot of new
infections with that variant
yes
and the other reason i'm worried is that
there is some inequity in the
distribution of the vaccine yes so 10
countries have i think 70 of the
available vaccine um and there are more
than 10 countries in the world yes
so so it's going to take i think up
until 2024 2025 until
vaccine can be distributed worldwide
um and because viruses don't care about
national borders
that means coronavirus is going to be
something
that we deal with for a very long time
even if
countries
wealthy countries do a great job of
vaccinating
and and regardless in all circumstances
the quicker we can vaccinate now the
better everybody is right i mean all
else being equal
that's right so right now the way i see
it we're in a race yeah
and the race is between the mutation
rate of
these coronavirus variants
and
vaccination
so the faster we can vaccinate people
the fewer cases there are the fewer
chances to mutate there are
makes up makes makes perfect sense
jonathan berman professor national
co-chair of the 2017 march for science
and also author of anti-vaxxers how to
challenge a misinformed movement i
really appreciate your time today thank
you so much sorry about my doggy no
everybody loves the dog